goianinha e aí alencar assistiu tudo bem
com vocês
o game e aí seus carros de bois é como
vocês podem ver o fim henrique coltre
uma empresa pra mim né eu estou no rio
de janeiro aí e e ele sabe que me trouxe
aqui vocês gente muito obrigado a todo
mundo que infernizou a vida da regina
casé para poder levar o esquenta porque
enfim é o bicho-papão macumbeiro que fez
o perdeu outra vez realmente muito
obrigado de coração a todos vocês que
isso fora agora eu terei muito obrigado
muito obrigado vão deixar a conversa e
vamos ouvindo então se você está no
facebook já curte logo para poder me
ajudar você sabe como é que é a parada
vamos lá onde eu fiz um vídeo
respondendo às perguntas do pessoal do
twitter um pedido pessoal mandar
perguntas pra mim e eu respondia que na
campanha pra vocês que teve uma pergunta
que eu deixei para responder depois para
dar uma prioridade é porque enfim todo
mundo perde um clássico nervoso a
pergunta foi porque um amigo não pode
ser um futuro namorado quem falou que
não pode agora você está assistindo
agora você que é homem ou 60 mulher você
quer um homem barra mulher não sei deixa
de ser burro gente não existe parceiro
melhor para seu namorado do que um amigo
sérgio é sério a maioria das respostas
quando a pessoa pergunta assim cara
porque eu não posso ser seu namorado
velha ela responde assim não dá cara não
dá porque a gente é amigo não queria
estar a isso
caras homens quando a mulher fala isso
não é por mal não é normal é que a
mulher ela já é mais sentimental ela
sabe o que ela vai sofrer sofre diretas
off off mulher foto é o bicho mais
guerreiro que eu já vi nessa terra e
sofrem vitter cardoso por sua mulher aí
não aguentavam e é sempre surge esse
amigo que vai ficando próximo vai
ficando próximo próximo próximo e pensa
assim cara roxa velho coxa por isso
namorada dela e ela não quer não é por
mal cara é simplesmente porque eu não
quero estragar esse negócio que vocês
têm tipo aí eu quero namorar
aí depois de três meses não dá certo que
acontece você sabe acontece geralmente o
cara sizandro e não dar só não fala mais
com ela por isso que para a mulher um
amigo não pode ser o futuro namorado
agora mulheres
abram seus olhos a dica que eu dou pra
você e eu eu o anderson nunes a dica que
eu dou pra você é mamori com seu amigo
está porque porque não tem coisa melhor
do que você namorar com aquela pessoa
que você conhece você entende você sabe
como é que é porque o cara que vai
conhecer na balada o cara que vai
conhecer no parque na rua ele vai fazer
de tudo pra te agradar tudo ligado à
tomada de rock gosto bloco adoro rock
como gosta de forró boa forró forró no
peito que é nordeste
você gosta de que tipo de comida eu como
de tudo eu como como como o frango boi
como vaca cavalo jumento e vai concordar
em tudo caro e vai concordar em tudo
porque porque quer você na verdade que
tinha como abrir o olho mas é um amigo
não tenho amigas que a opinião própria
sabe essa blusa aqui tá botar não tira
bota a opinião dele é sincera opinião na
mídia diferente a opinião do cara que
quer você quer abrir o olho
é esse outra coisa mulheres fosse fez
tem que parar em um acerto parar você
tem que parar com essa mania de ignorar
os cargos ligado a fulano foi muito
fulano está namorando e não é só meu
amigo pense num cara dói e ignorar é
muito fácil ignorar muito fácil é muito
fácil embora possam não quero quero ou
não quero não quero agora ser ignorado é
o cara que é ignorado e fica
naquela viu foi um cara ignorado e fica
se sentindo aquela posição de
incapacidade brigar com um cara como eu
não consigo ficar vez o menino claro é
isso que faz com que o cara se distancia
da menina aí o cara tá assim um amigo de
butko o meu melhor amigo da mina time
consiga caraca vai dar pra acontecer uma
coisa legal aqui ela fala que não quer o
cara fica naquela bem aí ó ó homens você
também tem para ser besta porque a
mulher mulher é um bicho lindo que deus
criou a mulher é coisa que merece amor
merece carinho merece tudo agora é só
pisar na gente então se ela não quer dar
um tempo talvez vai que ela sente só
falta e aí queira tipo aconteceu comigo
já aconteceu comigo ato anos quatro anos
eu quis o menino e é o nome que o nome
que não quis mais
háháhá então perguntei aqui para a
galera do twitter o que eles acham disso
com essa rodada da gay é que eu estou
falando como se tivesse alguém aqui do
thomson também atrapalha do twitter o
que eles acham disso então vamos ver o
que a galera do twitter está falando
sobre isso agora e nem repórter da globo
falei com o alex oliver disse
o enderson porque o garoto sempre falam
isso porque elas são garotas a história
do garoto sempre vai ser se não a gente
é só amigo cabo a jup tentou isso porque
quando você fica com o amigo as coisas
ficam estranhas e amizade nunca mais a
mesma
outra coisa que eu não não pra mim isso
não existe o negócio é quando você fica
com um amigo você acha que todo mundo
mas nada mudou
falei você só passa a língua está tudo
igual cara vai preste atenção ópera
atenção você fez uma coisa com seu amigo
que você nunca tinha feito antes vocês
fizeram
tudo cá vocês são o outro é pra mim olha
pra mim quando você ficar com amigos eu
não ficou standard não ficou estranho
não ficou estranho outro dia você chega
na escola assim aí cada um dia e tudo
vai ser como era antes cara isso disse
negócio que a gente tem não existe for
peace action em wimbledon e eu não tenho
nenhuma pergunta mas quando você pode
mandar o mesmo caminho dele que eu posso
um beijo pra você
ai juiz perguntou isso como saber se um
cara gosta mesmo de você ou só quer se
divertir muito fácil não tava só quer se
divertir ele quer você que é uma duas
três quatro cinco seis sete oito nove
dez anos até 2020 e 7 9 ventilado com um
cara que é só você atenção que você
recebeu outra é um bom dia vai carregar
os livros pra você vai tentar te fazer
sorrir o inter quando você começa a
ficar com sono e não vai deixar você
dormir vai começar a fazer coisas que
ele não faz por outros meninos ligados é
assim você também olha só vivendo
perguntou de novo isso porque quando
você está a fim de um amigo você quebra
a cara por favor é respondeu minha
pergunta para responder cara não é
projetar filho amigo sequer para tentar
fim da minha certo não adianta você
querer pegar a amiguinha que só quer ser
o coo da xuxa ela é do sabão em pó na
cara você tem que querer é aquela que
você quer a gata é difícil saber como é
que você quer porque tem às vezes temos
gasto na história da gente é o cara fica
outro fica agoniado roda nessa cadeira
identifica naquela faça a escolha certa
escolha menina certo e você não vai
quebrar a cara só isso não seja um tosco
também made in japan tentou estou
ficando com um amigo que conheço há 11
anos mas tenho medo disso dá errado e no
final acabar também com a nossa amizade
que fazer fica o estádio agora só fica
se você tiver certeza de que você quer
de verdade pode ter um erro muito grande
no relacionamento de hoje em dia que é o
seguinte nenhum namora esperando
terminar um namoro daqui três meses aqui
quatro meses vem não vai dar certo você
tem que namorar pensando em casar em que
você saiba que vai terminar mesmo que
você saiba que não vai dar certo para
você tem que namorar pensando no futuro
cara eu quero um tapa essa menina que
daqui a dez anos vai voltar com emprego
e tal eu vou levar ela tudo melhor
lugar está o fazendo feliz é isso que
você tem que pensar então se você achar
que você vai ficar com esse mim para
sempre fique se for só para ficar
prestando aí ano a mariana azevedo de
chaves onde nunca mais foi a mesma
depois de um ano ficado entre amigos e
já falei isso
neste pessoal tá o exame sanguíneo de
som
william não fui eu e somente está em
torno disso porque as garotas sempre
usou isso como desculpa sendo que nós
homens nunca ligaremos pra isso eu acho
que a pior é quando esse atrito com isso
um amigo se tornar um namorado no seu
ponto de vista é bom ou ruim pra mim é
bom cara porque enfim você tá na moda
você vai estar namorando um cara que
você conhece
não é um cara que quer só só brincar
pode comer eu eu quase fui namorado de
uma colega minha assim não foi namorado
porque enfim né porque ela vacilou pisou
na bola
isolado pisou na bola furou a bola
acabou que não deu certo mas o amigo
dela normal
mamãe passou açúcar em mim revelou roder
assim sabe minha diversão sempre será os
dias dou isso quer casar
aí que ela desvendou isso através dos
sinais que pode perceber que realmente
está interessado em você
sim porque os sinais são os sinais né
não ficou muito ofensivo 7 pode sim
querido
sim ana virgínia eu não tenho nenhuma
pergunta mas poderia mandar um beijo pra
mim um beijo pra você
ana virgínia é minha fã e aqueles é o
meu vídeo então consegue dar pra vocês é
isso cara não deixe esse negócio de
amigo interferi é entre um
relacionamento bom cara também não dá
pra namorada qualquer amigo né você tem
que escolher fosse uma amiga tudo bem
você relaxar de verdade vai fundo carlos
se você é menina tem um amigo
interessado em você avalia o cara não
descarta a oportunidade só porque ela
tem um amigo não olha bem para ele esse
poste pois é um cara legal com ficará um
pouco esse cara que faz rice cara legal
pegar não faz isso dá uma chance pra
você pode ficar namorando com esse
carinho idiota que tem por aí então se
você está no facebook já clique em
curtir sua ajuda para e os
compartilhem marcando um amigo seu amigo
está passando por essa situação é muito
bom o cara que você tá aqui no youtube
não se esquece de dar aquela moral
clicando aqui e gostei porque se você
ficar eu gostei
os seus inscritos vamos ver que gostei
vou assistir esse vídeo vão comentar
também como é que embaixo um assunto de
relacionamento para o próximo vídeo eu
não vou ficar fazendo esse
relacionamento acionamento dos serviços
aleatória na hora de escolher uma
pergunta vocês e faça um vídeo é você já
passou por uma situação dessas tiver
passado é comenta embaixo prover que
você não está inscrito e meu canal é só
clicar aqui embaixo inscrever se até o
colégio lado meu piauí de teresina que
tem hoje em cancún é uma dessas provas é
conseguir mais curtidas em uma fan page
a fan page do do a fan page do grupo e
essa campanha está aqui em primeiro na
descrição do vídeo se você clica lá e
curtir
eu vou falar nessa gincana então ou sei
lá eu queria queria ajudar quem curte ir
lá muito obrigado está ajudando muito a
equipe me segue no twitter me assina
aqui no facebook e me segue aqui no
estadão para ver fotos legais letras
maravilhosas do mundo inteiro me tira do
piauí
muito obrigado pela atenção que você
curtir e gostei da atuação dos favoritos
cometer se estreia no canal falo